there's some of brazil's most remote and
untouched regions but now president
bosun ro wants to tap into the riches of
protected indigenous reservations his
proposed bill delivers on a campaign
promised to open up the land to mining
energy and other projects this is a big
step forward it depends on Congress but
we will face pressure from
environmentalists those people from the
environment if I could one day I would
confine them to the Amazon since they
like the environment so much protected
indigenous land accounts for some 13% of
brazil's territory that's too much for
paulson arrow he says it hinders
economic development his proposed bill
has drawn strong criticism from
indigenous tribes and environmentalists
while both soon arrow says they'll be
consulted any final decision on
exploiting lands would be placed with
Brazil's Congress also not was proposed
bill brazenly violates Brazil's
Constitution which guarantees the right
of its indigenous peoples to
consultation this is the kind of
consultation that his Minister of Mines
and Energy has said will be but a
formality and not be carried out in the
rigorous manner that the Constitution
guarantees indigenous people have this
right enshrined in the Constitution and
other international convention and
they're demanding it today the far right
president says he wants to integrate
remote communities into Brazilian
society and in another controversial
move this week he named a former
evangelical missionary to head a
department responsible for protecting
uncontacted and recently contacted
tribes Brazil's three hundred indigenous
leaders opposed both Linares plans they
fear not just losing their lands but
their unique cultures to join the silver
al-jazeera